CHRISTOPHER JOHNSON: Hi.
Thanks for joining us today.
We're going to be talking
about "Mission Possible,
Moving Your Most-Sensitive
Data to GCP."
My name is Christopher Johnson.
I typically go by CJ.
I'm a security product manager.
I look after compliance,
regulated data.
And what we're talking
to you today about
are shared workloads
for government.
I have with me Suzanne.
SUZANNE KAO: Hi, everyone.
Great to see everyone.
I'm Suzanne Kao.
I'm a managing
director at Deloitte.
I oversee our global
export controls practice
and focusing on
regulations related
to export controls,
as well as sanctions,
and working with CJ today on
this fantastic presentation,
so looking forward to it.
CHRISTOPHER JOHNSON: All right,
well, at the very base of this,
we want to talk about the
challenge of compliance
in cloud.
Compliance, what we've learned
over the last couple of years
is, a lot of the regulations,
a lot of the compliance
regimes that we look
after weren't written
with cloud computing in mind.
And a lot of them
reflect requirements
that come from previous
world of having everything
in a single data center
or in a single room.
And our customers require
something a little bit more
complicated than that.
However, as we move to
this, managing compliance
with multiple data security
regulations in a cloud
environment can
be really complex
and slow, especially
for government agencies.
And this is what we've
really been thinking about
in trying to imagine
solutions for this.
It gets extra
complicated when you
have workloads
that have to comply
with multiple different
compliance and export
regulations.
I'll let Suzanne talk
a little bit more
about the cloud
compliance landscape.
SUZANNE KAO: Thanks, CJ.
So talking about the cloud
compliance landscape, when
it comes to sensitive data
and moving to the cloud
environment, there are
a lot of regulations
that you have to consider.
Amongst them is export controls,
as well as cybersecurity.
And what those
really regulate are
who can have access, what
can be uploaded to the cloud,
and then how can it be accessed.
So thinking about
that, export controls
can be quite stringent when
it comes to sensitive data
or controlled data.
And so as you can
see, it restricts
the unauthorized transfer
of technology and data
to non-US persons from an
export controls perspective.
So there are a lot of
different mechanisms
that a company can
employ to make sure
that it's in compliance
with these regulations.
And one of them is--
one of the leading practices is
marking that data as controlled
or not controlled.
And because of the fact that
export control regulations are
so stringent, a lot
of other regulations
can piggyback off the
various different compliance
requirements.
So for instance, when it comes
to cybersecurity regulations,
which govern the confidential
unclassified information,
and in other instances,
classified information,
being able to employ a
program where you're already
marking the data
can also capture
some of the cybersecurity
requirements as well.
But certainly,
there are some times
that there are conflicts
with these regulations.
So for instance, in certain
jurisdictions around the world,
there is a lot
around data privacy
and with respect to nationality.
So if you're thinking about from
an export controls perspective,
where you need to identify
who the non-US persons are,
there are
considerations that you
have to resolve when
it comes to sharing
that kind of
personal information
in order to be in compliance
with the export controls.
And there are
different mechanisms
that you need to think about
when you're trying to determine
who, what, and how.
And some of those are through
performing such things
as screening, where you identify
certain parties that you can
or cannot do business with,
licensing, which really means,
is about, should
you need to have--
provide access to a non-US
person, from that perspective,
there are licensing mechanisms
that you can actually
ask the government for
permission to do so.
And then, also
visitor management--
so in the instances that you
have a physical facility where
you're needing to
look at, whether it's
the physical parameters of the
building, or the server rooms,
or whatever it might be, there
are other protocols around that
to control who and who
doesn't have access
to those types of
physical locations.
And that relates also
to access control.
And that is from a
virtual perspective
such as in the
cloud environment,
where it's technology, or
it's a physical access.
And then with respect
to disclosures,
just like in
cybersecurity, if there
are instances of
non-compliance, there
are ways in which
you can actually
disclose those types of
incidents to the government
and to resolve those
sort of situations.
But as you can see,
it's quite complex.
And there are a lot of
different considerations
that come into play when
it comes to compliance
and moving to a
cloud environment.
However, should you have the
right protocols in place,
and of course, the right
tools in place to make sure
that you do monitor the who,
how, and what of the data,
and the access of that data,
and the controls of that data,
then it creates a smooth
transition for such a platform.
CHRISTOPHER JOHNSON: Migrating
government data to the cloud
is challenging.
And there is a few
key questions that
must be answered
before you get started.
And really, cloud users need to
be confident of their answers
before they can
start the migration.
And pretty soon, we'll
get to the solutions
to these problems.
But for now, let's
understand a little bit more
about what it takes.
You have to really
understand what
information will be
stored or accessed
in the cloud environment.
As Suzanne mentioned,
that goes back
to one of the fundamental
pieces of this,
is understanding
your information
and tagging it appropriately.
The next is where will that
information ultimately reside.
That could be
on-prem in a server.
That could be in the
cloud environment.
But it also is really
important in terms
of choosing which regions,
which cloud regions your data
is stored in.
We'll talk here in a few
more minutes about that.
And then we also
need to understand
what the process is to
grant and manage access
to that information.
What are the controls
that are in place?
Some of those,
you get to inherit
from the cloud provider.
And some of those, you
need to manage yourself,
in terms of looking
after the data,
making sure you have the
right controls in place.
That, of course, feeds directly
into the next question, which
is, who can access that data?
So we put this great
access control around it.
Now you need to make
sure you're controlling
the people that have access to
the information appropriately.
Do they have the right
attributes to access
the data in the first place?
Do they have the right
background checks?
These are really
important considerations
that feed into the question
of who can access that data.
The next question
to answer here is,
what is the process to add
content to the application
system or platform?
So we've spun up
our environment.
We've put all these awesome
access controls in place.
We have the right people.
Now we need to
understand what it
takes to move data in and
potentially out of the platform
or out of the
environment once you have
things configured and working.
The next one is what the
encryption protocols are
and how keys are managed.
This one's actually pretty
exciting, and one of the areas
that we really try to
help our customers out
with in Google Cloud.
And if you're talking
about US government data,
it has to be FIPS 140-2
validated cryptography.
And it's really important
that you have that in place
and you have good controls
around the cryptography that's
used, but you also have
to have a lot of options
in terms of managing
the encryption keys.
And in the Google
Cloud environment,
you have a lot of choices
with customer managed
encryption capabilities,
and all of those, of course,
being FIPS 140-2 validated
and turned on by default.
And then finally, how and
where are the data backups
being stored?
Where is this information
being stored and processed?
This is also a
key consideration.
And some of it is baked into
the environment directly.
But in other cases,
you need to make sure
that you're managing
this yourself.
SUZANNE KAO: And I just wanted
to add to some of the points
that CJ raised.
And I think these are really
critical questions when you're
thinking about migrating to a
government-- government data
to a cloud platform, is that
you can see that it really
is about multiple
responsibilities
and multiple
responsibility owners,
where thinking about
what information is going
to be stored, where the
information is going to be,
how is it going to be
accessed, and so forth.
And so even thinking about
our relationship, Deloitte's
relationship with Google
and working with CJ's team,
that's really been
a collaboration.
And being able to identify
and having those answers
very clearly laid out for these
various different questions,
that will inevitably create
that pathway and that journey
to being able to do that
migration very smoothly.
CHRISTOPHER JOHNSON:
So now we get
to make the transition to
my favorite part here, which
is we spent a lot of time
talking about the complexity
and challenges and the things
that Google and Deloitte are
doing to make this
easier and try
to help our customers
through the migration
and bringing their most valuable
information to the cloud
provider.
So we have a new product
called the Shared Workloads
for Government.
And this is our
solution to the problem.
The idea is, you're going to
secure your sensitive workloads
and accelerate your path to
running compliant workloads
on Google Cloud.
And we're going to talk a lot
more about what that means
and how we're going about that.
So Shared Workloads,
what is this product?
Basically, this product
allows you to confidently
secure and configure
those sensitive workloads
in alignment with the government
requirements and regulations
in just a few clicks.
You get to choose your
compliance security settings.
And we're going to put
the necessary cloud
controls in place.
It doesn't mean
you're off the hook.
You do have shared
responsibility here.
As both Suzanne and I
mentioned, it's really important
to make sure that that data
is managed and controlled
correctly.
But on our side, on the Google
Cloud side, we're making it--
we're streamlining that process
to configure the environment,
make sure it's set
up appropriately
for those compliance outcomes,
and getting you started
on the path towards compliance.
How does this work?
Well, for starters,
you log in and start
using a Shared Workloads.
This is available
from the Google Cloud
console, which we'll show
you here in a few minutes.
And you access the Shared
Workloads interface.
This is optimized for customers
in regulated industries.
And it's as simple as using
this New Workload button.
We're using this
workload concept
to put this
information together.
You set up your new workload.
This is where you configure
your platform controls
for data location,
administrative access,
and encryption.
Again, back to what we
were talking about earlier,
these are those
fundamental questions
you have to answer before
you start moving government
data to Google Cloud.
You have to understand
where your data is going
to be stored and processed, who
can access that information,
and make sure that the
appropriate encryption is
in place.
And then finally, monitor
your project details.
So make sure that
the environment
is set up appropriately and
that you're keeping track
of that environment over time.
And we help you with the
Shared Workloads product.
So we'll talk through a little
bit of the use case here.
I'll let Suzanne
describe the use case.
SUZANNE KAO: Sure.
So a typical scenario that we
really see that I think really
captures why something like a,
quote, "tool" like this would
be really useful is, for
instance, an aerospace
and defense client.
So if you have an aerospace
and defense client,
if you're familiar with export
controls, a lot of their data
is export controlled.
And also from a
government perspective,
that's the key thing.
And so when you're looking at
the aerospace and defense where
they have very
controlled information,
they're going to
be subject to a lot
of different
regulatory requirements
when it comes to the type of
data that might potentially
be shared with other entities
outside of its organization,
or even within its
own organization.
So the scenario is the client is
already using a cloud platform.
And then it acquires,
which often,
many aerospace and
defense companies do.
They buy up a lot
of smaller companies
and incorporate them into
their IT environment.
But of course, with
a smaller company
that might be less
sophisticated,
there may be some risk around
the identification of what's
controlled or not controlled
on their on-prem data that's
being stored.
And so they would
need to then go
through the exercise
of understanding what
that data is, and as I mentioned
before, potentially having
to mark it to understand what's
controlled and not controlled.
But the client wants to
move quickly to and migrate
the acquisition's
data into the cloud
and also make sure
it's showing compliance
with the various different
export control regulations,
as well as cybersecurity
regulations, and so forth.
And so the acquired company's
data is export controlled.
So then the situation is, how
do they do that quick migration
into the cloud
that's already being
used by the parent company?
So then, with that, CJ, do you
want to talk about [INAUDIBLE]??
CHRISTOPHER JOHNSON: Yeah.
So we're going to
step you through this
and show you a demo of this.
And we're going to show you
an aerospace user that's
going to create a
new workload with
multiple regulatory compliance
requirements for the data.
We're going to talk about
storing and processing
that data in the cloud,
and requiring, for example,
customer-managed encryption, US
data location, and US persons
controls in terms of
support of that data.
So I'll show you the demo.
We're going to come
into Cloud Console.
And for starters, we'll
come over to the menu.
You can see we have a
new Compliance area.
We're going to click in there.
And this is going to take you
directly into Shared Workloads.
In this case, we can
create a new workload
and view the ones
that we've created.
I'm going to go ahead and
create a new one here today.
Let's fire this up.
We'll call this NEXT Demo.
And we're going to tie
it to a billing account.
Next you're going to choose the
platform controls that you'd
like to apply to the workload.
In this case, we've got
IL4 and CJS turned on.
IL4 allows us to create
a workload that's
compatible with IL4 controls.
Specifically, it's going
to limit Googler access,
so Google support access
to only US persons.
We also have CJS options.
CJS does something very
similar, but it also
enables support for escorted
access to support use cases.
We're going to use IL4 today.
What happens next is the
regions that are available to me
are limited based
on the compliance
framework that we've chosen.
In this case, IL4 only
support the US regions or US
regional of data.
So only US regions
are available to me.
I'm going to choose us-central1.
And now I can see which
GCP services are available.
This will limit the capability
to the services that
are compatible with
these controls,
both for regionality and
personal access controls.
We're going to click Next.
Then we're going to
configure the encryption.
We'll start this thing up
today, set the rotation period,
and then click Next.
We'll review the workload.
What you can see
here is we've worked
very hard to make this
an extremely streamlined
experience for creating
a new workload,
putting the controls in
place, and getting you
ready to onboard data into GCP.
I'm going to create
the workload.
What's going to happen here, as
I mentioned, in the platform,
we're going to
create the project,
both for the shared workload
as well as for CMEK.
So we have some separation
of duties there.
And we're going to put the
back-end infrastructure
and controls in place
to protect the data
in a compliant fashion.
We can go in here and get
some details on the project.
It's going to give
us the platform
controls that were applied.
It'll show us the
controls specifically
that were applied in this case,
which are data access controls
and data residency.
We can see the region that
was chosen, obviously,
the creation time, and then
the projects themselves.
Like I said, it'll
create one for CMEK.
It'll create one for
the shared workload.
And it'll show you
the services that
are in scope for that
particular workload.
We, of course, can
launch into the project.
And at this point, I can
begin onboarding data
into the platform in
a compliant fashion,
creating VMs, creating
workloads, and really starting
to take advantage
of the platform
in a compliant fashion.
As you can see from
the demo, we've
worked really hard to make this
process as streamlined and as
efficient as possible for
creating a new compliant
workload.
And what we've done
there is, we've
put those guardrails
around your environment
and your infrastructure
to make sure
that you can have those
compliance outcomes in the end.
And ultimately, the
product features
that we're talking about
and demonstrating here
is the automatic enforcement
of those data location
constructions.
So in the case of the
US government compliance
requirements, these
have to be stored
at rest in specific US regions.
What we're able to
do with this product
is help you configure
that so that it'll only
be stored at rest
in these US regions
and also make sure that your
users of your environment
don't accidentally
store it somewhere
that they're not supposed to.
So we're compliant
from the beginning.
And then we help you put
those guardrails in place
to prevent misconfiguration
errors that
could result in a
non-compliant configuration.
So that's the first
part of it, which
is the automatic enforcement
of that data location.
The next part is
personnel access.
This one is actually
very interesting.
What we're able to do is
limit Google personnel access
based upon predefined
attributes such as citizenship,
a particular geographic
location, or potentially,
background checks.
So for example,
the support for CJS
allows us to have
controls in place that
make sure that it's a US person
accessing from a US location
with a very specific
background check in place,
or they're escorted
by somebody that is.
Finally, the built-in
security controls here,
this reduces the risk of
accidental misconfiguration
by choosing the available
platform security
configurations.
And we'll help you put
those controls in place.
Again, the idea here is start
from a compliance beginning
and then help you
keep that in place
as you move through the
lifecycle of your data on GCP.
Automatic enforcement of
products deployment location,
this allows you to restrict
the deployment of new resources
to specific Google
Cloud regions based
upon an organizational policy.
Next, the security and
compliance monitoring,
we're working on this now.
It's coming in Q4.
And this will allow you
to continuously monitor
the security and compliance
of your Shared Workload
environment and adjust
those settings as needed
based upon your own security
and risk assessment.
There is also premium
support offering here
for Shared Workload customers.
This allows you to ensure that
only US persons support from US
locations are available
24 by 7 to help
meet compliance requirements.
And this does require
additional support services
purchase though.
So the premium support
offering is quite interesting.
Thank you so much
for your time today.
It was a blast getting
to introduce Shared
Workloads for Government.
We're really excited about it.
And thank you so
much for your time.
Suzanne, thank you so much
for helping us out with us.
SUZANNE KAO: Oh,
it's been great.
And it's been a fun time.
And it's been a great journey.
So I really appreciate being
able to participate today.